[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con hoy
hablaremos de la reactivación económica
en nuestra región pese a que países como
colombia brasil y argentina se
encuentran en una delicada situación
epidemiológica debido a la pandemia de
kobe 19 para conversar sobre este tema
nos acompaña el doctor carlos alberto
pérez médico infectólogo de la
universidad nacional de colombia y
también asesor científico de france24
doctor lo saludo muy buen día que
elementos han provocado que américa
latina haya sido la región más afectada
por la pandemia y como pueden estos
factores afectar a su recuperación para
la salida de esta crisis
lo que hemos visto en la región raúl es
que definitivamente la desigualdad
económica y el trabajo informal ha
obligado que las situaciones de
confinamiento sean las con unas
situaciones que no hayan sido
procedentes como en otras partes del
mundo porque han llevado realmente a
empeorar la situación económica de las
personas y eso ha terminado en un
estallido social que hemos visto en
donde las personas tienen que saber
trabajar y ha hecho que estas mediante
restricciones no sean efectivas en la
región y hayan frei de esta problemática
que está volviendo actualmente ahora
doctor a pesar de la evolución
preocupante de esta crisis sanitaria
vemos un afán de la región por retomar
cuanto antes la actividad económica
aunque es totalmente comprensible le
pregunto si es prudente
el concepto de los científicos y de los
médicos y de las personas que trabajan
en los hospitales es que definitivamente
hay que hacerlo con gradualidad con
monitor y ahí estamos de acuerdo crear
la reactivación económica pero no es el
momento de hacerlo en todos los frentes
sino hacerle una forma gradual pausada y
siempre acompañado de testeo aislamiento
y adecuado manejo en los hospitales de
tener una capacidad infraestructura
hospitalaria entonces estamos ad portas
de una nueva crisis que va a ser con
esta situación de la reactivación en
todos los frentes económicos que no
estamos de acuerdo ahora como explica la
reapertura total de la actividad
económica en colombia por ejemplo
mientras el país atraviesa un pico de
contagios de fallecidos porque hoy 19
este miércoles por ejemplo se registró
un nuevo récord con 550 muertes
reportadas en las últimas 24 horas
en colombia hemos visto que más de 150
sociedades científicas de todos los
órdenes le han pedido al gobierno que no
haya esa reapertura que los esquemas que
ha utilizado de indicadores
epidemiológicos no son suficientes para
poder ampliar esta está reactivación
económica y que se guarde la prudencia
de la monitoría y la gradualidad en
colombia digamos en una disociación
entre lo que habla el gobierno y lo que
dice las sociedades científicas y
estamos seguros de que el gobierno
tendrá que escuchar a los científicos
porque los números pues son evidentes
inicial enteramente del número de
fallecidos si no hacemos algo pronto
doctor qué elementos son clave para
mantener el equilibrio entre la
reapertura económica y el control de la
pandemia
nunca hay una dicotomía entre salud y
economía
todos sabemos que parte de la salud es
tener una economía saludable pero para
eso se ha hecho un diseño que hemos
estado implementando en el tiempo que se
llama gradualidad monitoría y un
perfecto control epidemiológico entre
los números y lo que se puede permitir
haciendo en la hora de tener brújula y
control sobre las situaciones nadie está
diciendo que sea algo perfecto pero sí
que sea algo ordenado no solamente
responsabilizar a la sociedad de sus
actividades no solamente tengan la
responsabilidad que es estatal en los
ciudadanos es una estrategia por eso es
llamado a la sensatez a retomar el
control en las actividades para poder
hacer una respiración de económicas el
doctor le preguntó por último está la
región en un alto riesgo de caer aún más
profundo en esta crisis sanitaria con la
reapertura total de la economía sumada a
un lento proceso de vacunación
definitivamente lo que va a cambiar la
pandemia de hacer la vacunación ya hemos
visto como la vacunación también es un
marcador de desigualdad en donde en
todas las economías que se han abierto
ha sido porque la vacunación es exitosa
y nosotros ante vacunación incipiente
hacemos la apertura económica el llamado
es a acelerar los procesos de vacunación
a no reactivar todo de una sino hacerlo
en una forma gradual y definitivamente
al llamar a la solidaridad de entre los
gobiernos y la comunidad y los actores
civiles para que guarden la sensatez y
guardemos la prudencia en estos momentos
tan difíciles y podamos hacer todo
gradualmente en el tiempo doctor gracias
nuevamente por estar con nosotros que
tengo usted un feliz resto de día
ustedes también gracias por acompañarnos
siempre aquí en france 24
[Música]